is with us in New York
hi Hilde and welcome to the Dave Ramsey
show hi Dave
I just want to start off by saying thank
you so much for everything that you do
and peace well thank you how can I put
out a gratitude I started coordinating
SPU this year for the first time by
using experience yeah thank you but so
my question for you is um I'm 56
I am a single mom my daughter's now 34
I'm late to the retirement saving game
but I'm out there swinging an ax I'm on
step 6
about 40,000 left to go to pay off my
mortgage but and I earn about a hundred
thousand a year pre-tax pretty business
expenses my question for you that I
really wanted to pass by you is I do
feel partially my daughter just
graduated with a master's degree 34 at
34 she worked for quite a few years
before she went to undergrad okay yes
she's a grown woman that made a decision
to go get a master's degree in what in
art mm-hmm okay
and what is she going to do so she's out
there swinging to utilize that degree
and earn her living - no doubt what's
she gonna do well she is on the track to
be a gallery artist she's working with
galleries she's selling her artwork that
rule okay good um and the masters helped
her do that oh yeah because the worse
she got it I mean um she got it from
Yale it's the networking is quite a bit
it's important I think particularly for
that track but um when she went to
undergrad I remember distinctly heard
turning to me because I have always
personally though I have not been
terrible at saving money I've never I
don't have that I hate it but she did
turn to me and and say what do I do
I can't I'm gonna have to take out loans
to pay this and this was when she went
into undergrad and I remember distinctly
saying to her I guess you take out loans
it's what everybody seems to be doing
we'll figure it out later
so I do feel now tremendous partial
responsibility for the debt level that
she has why partial so she was a grown
woman she decided what she was going to
do called you up and said well she was a
grown woman when she did her undergrad
you said certainly and I am just getting
a handle on this and it's because of
your program you know so I kind of you
know that's different than you being
held responsible for her decisions and
that's oh yeah I know she has not asked
me for anything she doesn't even know
I'm thinking about so much student loan
debt did she run up to get her master's
in heart at Yale well it's about eating
cells oh good lord
oh well that's undergrad and grad good
lord but here's the question I wanted to
ask you and just be concrete here if you
think it's a good idea but um so my net
worth is not very high at this point but
and most of its in my house my thinking
is okay we ran out of time so you'll
have to hold through the break we'll
come back and get your question and we
are talking about your daughter who got
a master's degree in art from Yale is
$80,000 in debt at the time that she
took out the loans you all had a
discussion and you were feeling worried
for her and kind of heading towards a
question where you find where you want
to help you're not responsible you're
absolutely not responsible here's my
question Dave I what do you think if I
sell my current house and try and create
a win-win situation at the end of which
I would definitely have a much smaller
house but
goal would be to be mortgage free and
release about 40,000 and equity that I
would put down on her loan I don't think
you're wealthy enough to do that yeah
you're 56 you have no retirement and
about a hundred thousand every day yeah
you need to be building retirement and
you need to have a paid-for home when
you come into retirement if you had ten
million dollars or a million dollars and
you want to pull 80 grand out and pay
off your loans just as a gift not as an
obligation or a responsibility which I
don't think either are here but if you
just want to do that as a gift it'd be
fine but you don't have the margin this
is going to affect your retirement
dramatically
my thinking was again with the goal that
at the end of that I would be mortgage
for you in a smaller house you know and
then I could just keep swinging away at
putting money away at retirement so what
is your current home worth 2:30 and you
owe how much 40
okay so you got 110 or 210 equity arms
right on 190 equity not counting
expenses and you would buy a home that's
how expensive well my goal if I can make
it happen which is very difficult in our
area would be to buy one for like 130
[Music]
yeah there's only one reason here
there's only one yeah there's only one
reason you're doing this is you want to
help your daughter yeah that's the only
reason you're doing this yeah and that's
very very sweet I wouldn't do it I don't
think you're being financially
responsible if her Yale connections are
so valuable and her master's degree in
art is so valuable she'll make the money
to repay this loan mm-hmm you claim it's
worth that I have my doubts but you
think it's worth that and if you're
right then she should make the money to
repay this loan she's a 34 year old
woman if she married I see you thinking
great and what is his income about
seventy thousand what has she been
making in the art world what's our best
year my daughter yeah uh what she just
graduated in May so I I don't have a
yearly figure she's just painting and
trying to get her going she's been
selling artwork but I don't have per
piece how much money has she made since
May when she's selling artwork Oh may I
yeah I mean do you think she made 10,000
or 100,000 uh no I would say ten okay so
it sounds like if she duplicates that
and it grows that she could make forty
or fifty thousand dollars a year in the
coming years and her husband makes
seventy they make one money they can pay
off in eighty thousand dollars student
loan okay I appreciate that you're
worried about your daughter but don't
let that suck you into a tunnel a vortex
that causes you to do such damage to
yourself that I'm talking to you and
you're 80 and you don't have the money
for food because you start making these
moves out of this perceived guilt that
you have this perceived responsibility
that you have that frankly is not
accurate she made her decision to do
this you didn't and you didn't tell her
she had to you didn't tell her you'd pay
for it you didn't tell her any of that
and so um I don't I don't think she's in
a situation where she can't eat she's
going to have to buckle down and go
through Financial Peace University and
get these loans paid off and she's gonna
have to utilize the the degree and the
knowledge that she got in the art world
to make a good living to pay off this
money and prove that her theory in your
theory that Yale contacts make it worth
it so far they haven't so far she's made
ten thousand dollars and you don't pay
eighty thousand to make ten thousand
those aren't contacts that are worth it
but maybe they do evolve into something
I sure hope so that's my goal for
my wish for and your wish for thanks for
the call